awesome so so what am I here to talk
about tonight obviously you and I'll
come down to clover health to talk a bit
about you're doing data science in
healthcare as sort of a brief overview
of what we're gonna what I'm gonna tell
you about is you know we'll give you
another sort of introduction to clover
talk about the healthcare space in
general some of the rules and
regulations we deal with and then of
course the ways that data science can
help health care and the ways that we
can really do some certainly powerful
analysis on there I know you just got a
brief sort of introduction to to myself
earlier but and clover as a whole but
first we're gonna go over that so once
again just Who am I this life-size
picture actually might be fairly close
at this time is the basic summary of who
I am before this I was originally in
academia where I was studying operations
research at UC Berkeley I spent a good
amount of time there before I decided I
really wanted to focus on sort of the
practical applications of the theory
that we'd been working on it that I
found the best way to do that was to
teach myself to program so I left grad
school for a while really focused on
sort of Python and open-source
programming taking use of all the the
many sort of like free options that we
have in sort of the modern world and
then I bounced around for a while and
venture capital analytics which is a
horribly unstructured problem
surprisingly given how much money people
throw around in venture capital there's
like no real reliable data source so as
Ian mentioned I got really addicted to
horrible data and so I jumped over to
healthcare and obviously the most
important part of the thing about me
right now is that I work here usually I
just pointed this and say that I work
here at this billboard but I actually do
work in this building right now which is
a really cool experience here so so what
what is Clover health again well we are
far more than a billboard over New
Jersey
we are currently a Medicare Advantage
company so it is a private health
insurance plan for people on Medicare we
just checked the people who are 65 years
of age or older
we currently operate in nine counties of
New Jersey and we have about 18,000
members across those counties so just
before we go any further just to sort of
establish you know how like the health
insurance
skiing sort of works here right in in
traditional health insurance you you
have you know a pair which is the
insurer which would be us you have a
patient and a provider the patient will
pay a premiums to their their insurance
company they will also pay small you
know amounts to to the doctor's office
themselves and then we will ultimately
pay you know the provider much of the
the sheriff for their their services and
for their claims but how does that work
in Medicare Advantage so the difference
in Medicare Advantage is that now
instead of the member paying premiums us
almost everything is covered by the
government which subsidizes us based off
of what they believe to be sort of the
risk profile of each of our members you
know how of what have they been
diagnosed with if they're treated for in
the past year and then how much do they
expect that person it costs you like a
health insurance plan for you know all
their services that they would incur
over the next sort of year generally the
like the paradigms in health insurance
for how to profit right is you either
you know risk pooling where you just
insure as many people as possible that
are sort of low cost and you profit off
of the like small probabilities so these
really rare events or the other option
is to just deny claims you just refuse
to pay for things right save money that
way uh but we here at Clover sort of the
difference is you know naturally it's
not a unique proposition to be a health
insurance plan for Medicare right so
what is our sort of difference here well
we have this our thesis is that you know
we get basically a fixed subsidy for
each of these members throughout the
year and for what they think that
they're going to cost but then we
believe that by actually using you're
building a really efficient insurance
company and automating a lot of our
processes and using preventive measures
predictive analytics that we can
actually go in and identify you know
care gaps identify new diseases before
they manifest in these really acutely
expensive hospitalizations we can go in
we can identify those and then by
proactively treating things we can
actually change sort of the underlying
risk probabilities you know we can
change what we think members are going
to actually sort of costume here and you
know when I say modifying risk
probabilities that sounds all fun and
mathy but like what is the real
implication of that is that we're
actually you know improving health
outcomes for our members we were trying
to profit directly by you know giving
them a healthier experience by keeping
them you know healthy keeping them out
of the hospital
you know from really acutely expensive
hospitalizations
and ultimately that you know sort of
leads to it we profit now in sort of the
general sphere of data science right
this seems fairly straightforward you
probably have a lot of probabilities of
these things you can measure what your
members have done apply some really
complicated models and just spit out
answers right that would be nice but we
are in health care right and health care
is heavily regulated and tremendously
complex I'm going to bark this at you
multiple times including on this next
slide health care is heavily regulated
and tremendously complex
it's a crazy industry and so what do I
mean by this well first of all you know
heavily regulated right with our data we
have tons and tons of restrictions that
general in their current current
iteration we're handed down by HIPAA the
Health Insurance Portability and
Accountability Act HIPAA is a well
intentioned piece of legislation that is
supposed to keep you know protect our
members from having all of their
personal information leaked into you
know the public sphere especially with
the current state of technology now
HIPAA is also an endless source of
acronyms sort of the the crux of it here
is that you know HIPAA is run or
administered by the Department of Health
and Human Services if we want to share
our data with any other companies we
have to sign a very strictly negotiated
business associate agreement all this
protects us from leaking personal health
information or personally identifiable
information about our you know our
members or any of their illnesses or
anything that could be used to
essentially cause harm to to them and
then within the medicare sphere itself
you know we deal primarily with the
Center for Medicare and Medicaid
Services CMS there are also a million
other acronyms but it's sort of the crux
of it is that anything that we do here
not only has to be documented but it has
to be defensible right it goes well
beyond any of the normal sort of like
software practices where it's like oh
you need some documentation so that we
could redo this or so other people can
understand sir what you're working on is
everything that we do it has to be just
meticulously documented because we can
be audited at any time to make sure that
we are acting and sort of like the best
interest of our members and so if we are
audited and it finds out that we are not
we can get charged a lot of money and
have to pay a lot to a lot of people now
how much do we have to pay well I'm
really glad you asked that it is
hipa itself can looking at just the
maximum sort of fines on this can charge
you up to $50,000 per violation with an
annual maximum of one and a half million
dollars in one year that is more than a
fine or a slap on the wrist right that
is like a whole funding round for a
company if if you are caught you know
just miss handling sort of like your
your user data or leaking anything about
your members or just being willfully a
sort of ignorant all these sorts of
things now as I mentioned health care is
also tremendously complex so sort of the
other the other side the other
difficulty to this industry right is
that there is so many of you know
different payers that can come up for
everything there's so many different
rules so when you read your regulations
everything that we just have to deal
with um back in the 90s it became a
thing to attack health care this is
Arlen Specter currently attacking health
care in this photo and so the way to do
that was you take everything in health
care and you try to fit it on a board
now you probably try to fit it on a
large board but you're still obviously
going to fail because healthcare does
not fit on a board but to attack it you
try to do that and then you take this
board with you and you lug it around you
lug it around Washington DC you take it
everywhere and say look healthcare is
insanely complex I can't do this now
people still try to put healthcare on
boards today somehow this is still an
effective way to attack it but just for
a sort of an illustration here yeah this
is like a list of just a few of the
other payers that can come up so you
know if somebody has a claim like went
to a doctor for this service should be
straightforward oh we pay you know this
much but it can come down to you know
Medicaid other payers states you can
have multiple types of insurance here
you can have other catastrophic plans
all sorts of different things can factor
into this now considering you know
health care being heavily regulated and
tremendously complex
are you still on board for moving
forward with us you're all still here so
I'm going to say yes awesome
my next sort of thing to talk about then
when I say you know health insurance
technology or health insurance tech
stacks or what do you you picture
because I bet it's this yeah this is you
know surprisingly not far off for a lot
of health insurance companies right now
there is still COBOL floating around in
a lot of
basses if you are familiar with that
amazing language but thankfully sort of
the difference with with clover is that
you're we are a little bit more tech
forward so what does our tech stack
actually look like as I mentioned before
any you know company that wants to sort
of it would have to hold our data we
have to sign a very strict agreement
with so it sort of limits the number
people we can actually interact with but
you know we we end up using a fairly
good mix of Scimitar open-source tools
and then you know some private services
so what are these tools yeah like our
databases are in Postgres you know we
are repos are mostly in Python here our
engineering team will work a lot of
react we do a lot with with docker um
some of the services that we actually do
work with we do a lot of our like sort
of reporting and within the company
through our lovely compatriots mode
analytics who will be speaking to you
shortly after me
we store most of our databases on sort
of a very private server which is run
through through App table we also store
a lot of things in Amazon and then
naturally are sort of like our Python
repos or sequel repos all that will live
within github within the organization so
so given that sort of tech stack like
where does data science sort of fit now
this is very much the long form answer
to where to stay to science fit in the
organization don't stare too much at
this chart but what you should really
take from it is that you know as a data
science team here our responsibility is
basically to you know take healthcare
data from a lot of different sources
whether you've pharmacies providers labs
hospitals all sorts different things to
take all of that all this very often
like conflicting information and from
there you know we have to distill the
real people that you know underlie all
this health data we have to distill
their actual diseases that they have and
the diseases that we think they might
have we we process all of this you know
we send it out to like an Operations
team then this gives us feedback that we
have to keep processing and you know
keep moving forward with reporting now
obviously there's a lot of like
engineering or product functions that'll
come within that or operational
functions so what is what is data
science really boil down to as
illustrated by this lovely black box
there are about five things that we
really do here um we we count things we
clean things we automate things we mind
things and we
predict things of course the the real
question is that I get from everybody on
this is count things like really do do
you need a team of 15 people with
graduate degrees to count things and the
answer is yes the answer is absolutely
yes because counting is really hard
counting is absurdly hard sort of it's
it's a symptom right of when you take
these really complex real-world
scenarios and you try to fit it into a
nice sort of like simple data model that
you can hand around to like track oh
your members health no it's really nice
if it fits into your specific data model
and it doesn't change but if you get a
whole bunch of these data models
together they start arguing with each
other and before you know what you can't
find your way out you are deep in a
labyrinth and and your members are
somewhere on the other side but maybe
it's probably easier if I just show you
sort of why counting is hard right so
first off we'll count something really
simple we will just count employees so
these are the number the live employee
counts on LinkedIn of us and you're sort
of our 3 to like major competitors now
as you'll notice we are much smaller
than the other ones here um with these
really complex scenarios of course you
one way to do it would just be to count
on your fingers and they have hundreds
of thousands more fingers than we do but
but with our you know sort of like two
hundred boys we have to be very like
smart about the way that we actually try
to count things I mean health care um
but let's get into an actual real
example so let's try to just count
people let's let's count our members
what's like the first thing you would
want to do if you were building a health
insurance plan you'd probably want an ID
number for for all of your members that
that sounds straightforward right just
give everyone a unique ID well of course
in health care these IDs are not unique
they never were even the system for them
for how you create this number is not
unique at all
Medicare IDs sort of like a rose when
they're like oh we'll just combine you
know social security numbers with
railroad retirement board numbers that'd
be nice and easy it ends up with mobile
different formats there's even a third
format as the Railroad Retirement Board
decided it was getting kind of dated and
would sort of update itself but how does
this sort of manifest itself and what
are the real problems with this well
let's just study the e be social
garetty number here in general most of
our members will have a hicken which is
their health insurance claim number sort
of their their main identifier here
which is a social security number and a
letter I notice I said a social security
number it is not necessarily your social
security number because well-being you
know 65 can make you or can qualify you
for Medicare you may actually have your
eligibility if you haven't had a
sufficient number or a sufficient amount
of work experience with like a Medicare
eligible company your eligibility may
actually come through someone else so
say you're a 65 and you haven't worked
it for enough years to be actually
eligible but say or your partner is so
now you you are on Medicare
congratulations but your identifier is
their social security number plus a
letter that says that you're their wife
or you're their second wife or you're
they're divorced wife or you're their
child who is also Ellen here like really
there are more of these if you ever want
to just entertain yourself you can look
up these like hicking suffixes or
suffixes they get really interesting
there's there's one for being somebody's
alleged second father I can't really
explain that one to you um but so sort
of some like illustrative examples of
this right and these are things pull
actively from our database of course
I've changed their numbers because I
don't want to just do a live demo of you
know a HIPAA violation for all of you
like this first case here this is one
person who you know eventually ends up
being you know the a surgeon notes that
it's their social security number this
is them but you know at one point they
were you know somebody else's spouse and
before that they were also eligible on
another one we have another case here
where you know we have three members who
it's all using one Social Security
number and then you know case case three
down here right it's you know it's three
different people with four different
social security over four different
identifiers but you know one Social
Security numbers sort of tying them all
together it's one thing you know if we
actually see this we can actually track
somebody when they come through and we
can watch these changing so we can tie
them together but the fun thing is if
this person joins with with this number
here and then they leave and there
Changez and then their number changes
again and then they come back we don't
get the middle number it doesn't appear
we just get the the start and the end
and we just have to find way back into
there but but enough about people
themselves let's let's count another fun
situation in health care let's count
just providers
let's count doctors so what happens when
you go to a doctor right you you see one
person in one building and then you pay
we pay that one building and you know it
eventually gets back to the doctor right
because that's how this stuff always
works what's the real scenario look like
when you say go to a hospital for a
service it looks a little bit more like
this you have about four doctors who you
know may all be at one hospital but may
also belong to a physician's practice or
a physician like collective you think
you're saying just doctor Bob but your
results pass around that goes to these
doctors all over here we are supposed to
find you know the NPI which is like the
doctors identifiers we suppose to write
who with you actually visited but the
problem is who do we pay oh you'd assume
the hospital has one tax ID no the
hospital may have you know several
different tax IDs one for each wing plus
the hospital can have its own doctor IDs
because in health care hospitals can be
people in that case who do you pay that
is one of the things that is a lot of
fun to sort of count in health care but
you know maybe at this point we
shouldn't focus anymore so I'm like sort
of counting a lot of the data science
needs that we've had at Clover have just
been very sort of reactive it's been
sort of things that we absolutely have
to do like finding our members and
finding their doctors and figuring out
who to pay but sort of one of the more
exciting things as we've sort of done
this for a while and we slowly get more
and more on top of our data right we've
had these opportunities to do sort of
Morris or like proactive measures so do
some really sort of interesting
applications of like data science
principles and use some more sort of
complicated models now to preface this
one thing in healthcare just given the
fact that you know everything is so it's
tremendously complex you'd be amazed
just how much like even a small or a
simple sort of statistical model just
how much of an impact if that can have
on something in healthcare um let me
show you a few sort of examples of this
and those sort of things that we've done
here at Clover so first sort of a case
study
here on open enrollment it's the one
time of year when we can actually like
actively grab sort of members
interesting Lee there are only two
months where we can sign up like 95
percent of people on Medicare to our
plan
it is crunch time is you know mid
October made October great month mid
October to early December yeah it all
blurs together to October so one last
year in our open enrollment we we had
found that you know for all of our
marketing initiatives we were storing
all of ours in Salesforce they've been
like 15,000 of those right but you know
meanwhile when somebody actually enrolls
we get an enrollment that has to go
through through Medicare which is like a
really like rich data set but the
problem is you know it isn't enough to
know just how many leads like a
marketing initiative has sort of
generated that doesn't tell us anything
right what we really want to know is how
effective things have actually been at
generating members so ideally all these
leads would be directly connected to
their enrollments right well of course
they were not so so how do you how do
you sort of deal with that right you you
can go through it by hand and try to
match fifteen thousand people to seven
thousand other people but something
tells me that's not going to work out or
if it does you'll go about to lose you
know like several weeks of your life
trying to sort of connect these things
so we pass it around on the team we were
wondering sort of like what could we do
to actually find this so here's here's
what we came up with as it turned out we
actually somebody had manually connected
this stuff for 2014 so we have been able
to sort of see you know like how this
might actually work
what we found you know within Salesforce
which is all you know a hand entered and
is a lot of low quality well we'll just
call it low quality data right we found
that even though you know it came with
like 80 different columns and things
that we could use there were only maybe
five of these that actually had reliable
values everything now thankfully for our
enrollment data because that had to pass
through Medicare it was like very you
know very meticulously examined you know
it was rich all the fields and there was
sort of good so anything that we could
find in there that would maybe map to
one of these five columns might actually
be useful so what did we end up doing so
it turns out that if you just looked at
say like the the Edit distance 11 shine
distance between you know the first name
in enrollment the first name in we
last name in enrolment last name gonna
lead the city name on an actual
enrollment form the city name on the
lead and then just check ok maybe is
there an exact match on phone number or
an exact match on zip code but you could
run that and and just by throwing this
you know into a simple logistic
regression model right you can get
really hot call or a really high
precision which is a very very low
threshold you know you can get up to
four yeah guessing on like thirty five
percent of your leads you know if it
generates lead it's right like ninety
five percent of the time which is
amazing and instead of having somebody
go through this and do everything by
hand for many many hours we sort of
broke this in like one day and then just
ran overnight and you know the next day
it came back and we could actually look
at this sort of stuff and we could see
you know how many enrollments all the
way different sort of levers had
generated for us um
what yeah what let's look at another
sort of interesting like case study here
let's talk about pending claims right so
when somebody gets a service rate or has
a service done and you know their doctor
wants to be paid for it right they
submit a claim to us but claims won't
always be sort of processed immediately
right a lot of times they will sit in
sort of this pending state yeah just
sort of on it for a while so as a health
insurance company though it is very
important for us to know how much you
know all the claims that are currently
sitting at Penn that are sitting in this
sort of you know limbo right now how
much those may eventually cost us right
because we need to know how much money
to actually reserve on the side now it's
sort of the the standard way to do this
actually is is you look at you know all
of your claims all of your pending
claims and how much they ended up
costing for sort of like the past year
and you assume that okay the process
isn't going to change if we just look at
this sort of like month over month over
month but of course that assumes like
operational stability that assumes that
you were doing the same thing this whole
time now naturally we are a start-up and
things are changing all the time and to
assume that you know our operational
procedures now are the same as they were
a year ago is absolute madness right two
years ago we didn't even have a tech
office here and everything has been
changing we've been growing like like
crazy so we figured you know we this
sort of estimation method wasn't working
great for us so sort of what could we do
how could we possibly sort of get around
this well how could we generate more
reliable estimates well it turns out
that actually just by looking at a very
sort of like short time window of our
claims if you just look at say like the
claims more past month or assume that
maybe in the past like two months that
our operational procedure has been
relatively consistent so could we draw
sort of a random sample from that actual
group there and generate what we think
might be sort of like a prediction for
how much of the current claims that
we're actually sitting on are going to
cost so we you know we looked in this we
explored things for a little while it
turned out that like our pens court sort
of had this this bimodal distribution
over time we'd seen where it's like a
lot of them will be you know sort of
processed very quickly others will sit
so we're like two weeks there so we fit
a distribution to that and which is you
know like an exponential variable sort
of like a normal variable therefore to
make sort of like a joint probability
there and you know given how many days a
claim that had been sitting in are sort
of like our pending process we could
predict where was it part of this this
early set of claims or was a part of
this later side of claims and just using
a very sort of simple but weighted
average of these probabilities and you
know random draws and it found out that
like just using this past month we could
get within you know like 5% of what our
pending claims actually seem to be sort
of costing now naturally there's a lot
more testing to do on this and I can't
show you the actual numbers for things
because I'm not going to I am
withholding that from you but just the
amazing fact is you know just by giving
you this this like simple sort of
probabilistic distribution here that we
can actually generate fairly accurate
measures of claims using a very short
retrospective time window that would
hopefully be a lot more robust to
operational procedures now one last sort
of case study here for you and this is
like the the quintessential question
that we get sort of here
right it's like given you know every
public medications calls labs everything
that I remember has been through like
can we actually predict sort of their
their afflictions or diseases that they
they may sort of had so we took some
time here and we you know assembled a
bunch of our features and we sort of ran
some numbers here to see what these if
we could actually sort of predict us
predict this now these are ROC curves
here trying to predict whether remember
has you know diabetes or angina
now fully explaining an ROC curve is a
little bit outside of the scope of this
talk
basically what it's looking at is you
know given two people one who does have
a disease and one who doesn't how good
can good is any test at predicting which
person actually has it which person
doesn't this red line here would be sort
of like a coin flip right so you know if
you just arbitrarily chose one of these
two people it would end up being like
50% of the time you know you'd be right
you'd be wrong and it wouldn't really
have any sort of predictive value but
like if you were running a very reliable
test here right you would be able to get
a whole bunch of true positives without
getting any false positives at all you
would almost always be able to pick you
know the the person who actually does
have the disease and so we found that by
just like testing on some of our lab
data and a whole bunch of other
information that we had about our
members and like a current set right
that we can get almost up to this left
corner now the ideal test right is
always right and always gives you a true
positive I never gives you a false
positive and gets you up to there but
you know we found that just looking
through like fairly simple you know
fairly simple collections of features
about each of our members that we could
actually get you know fairly close there
at least for diabetes which is really
exciting and you know this is something
that of course we are we're going to be
refining for the entire time that we
were a company here because it drives
all sorts of different powerful analyses
that we can do from there so so sort of
like where to from here um so you know I
showed you as someone like the difficult
the difficulties that we have in
healthcare dealing with regulations and
you know dealing with just the
tremendous complexity of sort of the
industry you know I showed you like a
lot of the difficulties we have but just
counting things how hard it is to find
people and you know sort of some of the
more proactive or the the cooler sort of
data science applications and just how
effective simple models can be you know
in a space here that is very like for
very long time but traditionally just
sort of like outdated right that's
something that we're really trying to
change so you know going forward with
with clover we're finding that you know
the more that we learn about health
insurance the more that we realize that
we don't know right we are very much
trying to explore this industry
basically for the first time as a tech
company and you know we're trying to be
a data-driven healthcare company that
like everything we do we're trying to
learn as much as we can to drive sort of
our mo
you know for the future and yeah the
more that we actually discover the more
we realize we don't know and to some
people you know that could be very
daunting as you realize that once you
finally feel like you're on top of one
tiny sliver of healthcare that you have
this entire your vast space ahead of you
when I think of it it always reminds me
of this picture right that yeah we we
are some very very tiny dot who feels
kind of accomplished but then realizes
the scope of a universe it can be really
intimidating to some people but I
actually think it's uh it's pretty cool
and it's what keeps me in healthcare so
on that note that is all I have for you
today I'd be happy to answer any
questions
yeah so the question was you know that
we are trying to our business model is
trying to look made am i sort of acute
illnesses or so to to minimize cost and
what are we trying to minimize here um
so so really what we're trying to
minimize right is just anything we're
trying to minimize the amount of times
that somebody develops a disease right
any disease and it manifests itself and
an acute sort of like a hospitalization
just a rare event something that is
gonna happen one time and is going to be
like absurdly expensive in relation to
if we were able to just catch it
beforehand um frankly this this ends up
being you know all sorts of different
illnesses kind of the main example right
is diabetes because diabetes is the one
that affects more of our population than
anybody else yeah or than anything else
right and we've very recently been you
know operating a lot on trying to
predict which of our members that have
diabetes now or are about to develop you
know with complications or are most
likely to develop some much more
aggressive form of diabetes or another
disease related to that and so that
would be sort of like I'm a an example
but really it comes down to just
everything that I remember side
right right so it wouldn't be about
acute illnesses it would just be about
you know like really expensive
hospitalizations because you know that
shouldn't be a part of the routine for
anybody great
yeah so so asking sir today what more
predictive data about diabetes leads to
we believe leads to sort of
complications so I I haven't dealt too
much with the diabetes myself as Ian
mentioned before there you know 12 other
people roaming around I like the data
side Steve here who I'm sure would be
more willing to a or a more able to
answer I'm sorry but you know just would
within like sort of a feature graph they
were generating before I read we were
just combining you know everything that
we can about a member just from all sort
of different illnesses from all of their
lab data from all their you know
everything we get from providers
yeah so so what you know fraction of our
people of our current members maybe like
split up and may be represented as
multiple people said our data a sort of
the last time I looked at this we we had
seen like 20 2012 2013 or 23,000 Dickens
that had come through so you know sort
of like upper bounding that there right
that yeah it's roughly like yeah one in
like 10 people may have another ID
system so it's very important for us to
actually you know find the the unifying
step they're able to tie them together
so I can't say what the results are when
we just throw it a really bad data
hopefully it'd be really yeah
yeah so like as I'd just to sort of
reiterate there so like as I've
mentioned you know we've spent a very
long time just making sure that we have
sort of like the truth in our date and
being on top of our data warehouse here
and that's why you know we didn't really
start doing a lot of really crazy
predictive measures you know it's just
stuff that's developed over time as
we've slowly had opportunities to really
expand our analysis
yeah so so the question was here looking
at your like the different medical
systems or was the lag time for
forgetting member oh it varies is
probably the best answer here
Otis says it can be really low if the if
a doctor integrates
yeah for the recording there Otis says
it could take lifetime to get your
member data in real time all right on
that note I am currently out of time
thanks again everybody and I will pass
this back to you